and these priests are white yeah always  white middle-class or metropolitan  liberal elite types who say no you're  wrong on this issue of race calvin in  fact i've sat down with the bishop of  london and she said look as a white  woman i can tell you the church is  institutionally racist i'm like well  that's not my lived experience surely  your whole stick is that you want to  listen to the lived experiences of  ethnic minorities why not mine is it  because it doesn't meet the narrative is  it because it doesn't align with your  views is it true that you really want to  listen to us or is it just you want to  listen to the ones that you can pat on  the shoulder so you're a good black boy  you know you're going along with the  party line i think it's a new form of  racism actually ohio pancho